bonsoir emmanuel thomas merci d'être
avec nous on vient de lire la lumière
poutine qui affirme que le statut du
haut karabagh n'a pas encore été
déterminé que moscou maintenait le statu
quo une réunion a eu lieu à lieu demain
sur ce sujet et quoi faut-il s'attendre
selon vous alors je pense que une fois
ce cessez le feu obtenu sous l'égide de
la russie c'était la seule puissance qui
pouvait avoir une influence décisive
pour arrêter les combats
l'avenir du haut karabakh évidemment
n'est pas encore réglé nous revenons à
la situation d'un conflit gelé je dirais
puisque les arméniens aimerait
évidemment conserver ce qui reste du
haut karabakh mais les azéri considère
que tout le karabakh d'oeuvre est sous
administration azérie
et donc il y as rivalité des visions sur
sur ce territoire est en quelque sorte
pour stabiliser la situation à long
terme évidemment ce qui est décisif
c'est le la force de paix d'imposition
de la russie sans qui les armenian
aurait pas de sécurité
mais pour régler définitivement la
question du haut-karabakh sans doute que
les dj les grandes puissances vont à
nouveau se réunir et essayer de discuter
mais comme elles ont des intérêts
divergents il sera très difficile
d'arriver à un accord global et donc je
pense que la solution la plus probable
est le retour à une situation gelé alors
jean yves le drian demandé à moscou de
le lever
l'ambiguïté sur le cessez-le-feu le rôle
de la turquie et sur les combattants
étrangers
sincèrement on se pose la question le
groupe de minsk est toujours légitime
pour régler la situation sur place est
demandée ainsi des comptes
alors effectivement là il ya la rivalité
russo turque qui est derrière ce conflit
aussi même si la russie et la turquie
arrive toujours à de manière pragmatique
à négocier pour ne pas arriver à une
collision frontale et la turquie avait
demandé évidemment des de participer à
cette force d'interposition ce qui a été
refusé par la russie parce qu'évidemment
le haut karabakh le caucase du sud en
général c'est les 13 l'étranger proche
de la russie et la turquie est membre
autant il ne faut pas l'oublier donc la
russie ne pouvait pas donner un statut
égal à la turquie et a repris la main je
dirais à l'occasion de ce conflit
mais les le groupe de minsk a été
écartée des négociations pour établir un
cessez-le-feu
c'est assez logique si l'on analyse
l'évolution de la configuration
géopolitique mondiale en fait où les
institutions le groupe de minsk l'eau
scee l'otan l'union européenne afin
d'aider toutes les nations unies qui
avait pignon sur rue
cependant je dirais la guerre froide et
ensuite la période unipolaire où
c'étaient les états unis et les
occidentaux qui dominent et la scène
interne à international ces
organisations pouvaient gérer le
multilatéralisme et les gosses entre les
états mais aujourd'hui elle ne reflète
plus la réalité du terrain la réalité
géopolitique avec le retour de la russie
dans le dans son étranger proche
la montée en puissance de la turquie est
donc ce n'est plus le lieu principal des
négociations décisives mais évidemment
la france et les états unis vont essayer
de revenir dans le
jeu pour participer aux négociations et
invoqué de demander des réunions du
groupe de minsk
mais ce ne sera pas je pense pas que ce
restera le coeur de dispositifs pour
aider la question du haut karabakh
il faut voir aussi que la russe la
russie a réussi à endiguer la turquie
qui voulait un rôle beaucoup plus
important et la turquie membres temps et
s'est étonné en fait du du retrait des
états unis des occidentaux durant cette
crise
mon interprétation et qu' ils ont fermé
les yeux parce que la turquie
ça arrange les états unis d'endiguer la
turquie lorsqu'elles menacent de diviser
les membres autant par un par exemple en
méditerranée orientale mais retourner la
turquie contre la russie sert les
intérêts atlantiste et donc la russie
s'est extrêmement bien rétabli parce
qu'il faut pas oublier de le contexte
général où ou la russie subit la
pression en biélorussie le cren soutenu
par les états unis la géorgie aussi
qu'ils essayent de se rapprocher de
l'otan et de l'union européenne et la
sphère navalni et cette crise dans le
haut karabakh est venu se surajouter à
cet arc de crise et aussi en syrie où
les états unis en fait soutiennent la
turquie à église pour empêcher la russie
est là et la syrie loyal de bachar
el-assad avoir une victoire totale en
syrie donc vous le jeu est extrêmement
complexe
la victime qui dit avoir grandement
apprécié l'implication de la france et
des états unis dans le règlement de la
situation dans le haut karabagh septet
au fair play tout haut diplomate
mais ce qu'on peut dire quand même
clairement que son ce dossier la russie
était quasiment seuls à la manoeuvre
évidemment c'est la russie qui avait
toutes les cartes en main et en réalité
au delà de déclarations d'amitié de la
part de la france pour l'arménie une
tentative de cessez-le-feu humanitaire
de la part des états unis
la france aussi a participé
a demandé à ce qu'un cessez-le-feu mais
ils n'y sont pas arrivés parce qu'ils
n'ont pas toutes les cartes en main et
en réalité ils n'ont pas été capables de
faire pression sur la turquie qui est
derrière l'azerbaïdjan donc il n'y avait
que la russie qui évidemment a des
intérêts régionaux de sécurité c'est le
l'étranger proche de la russie et qui a
pu faire pression sur la turquie pour
imposer un cessez-le-feu et comme je
l'aï dit tout à l'heure
mon interprétation et qu'en fait la
plupart des pays de l'otan ne voulait
pas faire pression pour la turquie parce
que retourner la turquie contre la
russie arrange les intérêts atlantiste
et détourne la turquie je dirais des
intérêts des pays membres de l'otan en
méditerranée orientale
donc c'est toute la rue la russie avait
toutes les cartes en main et était seule
en fait pour imposer ce cessez le feu et
l'a réussi merci pierre emmanuel
tordjman professeur de géopolitique
fondateur d'euro continent